It's destroyed.
It gets fucking jacked.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is a special Sunday edition of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast.
And we wouldn't even be doing this shit if it wasn't for Jim Gaffigan.
Jim Gaffigan is hilarious and awesome and uh,
and we will talk about him later,
but right now let's talk about rubber vaginas cause we're sponsored by the
fleshlight.
Oh,
Shalane Alaykum.
Is it good?
Yes it is.
Is it embarrassing?
Fuck yet.
As you got to make your choices in this life,
you've got to pick your,
pick your ground.
You got to stand down.
Sometimes you got to stand up for what you believe in.
And if you masturbate,
this is better than that.
This is on the Christian Broadcasting Network,
right?
Yes.
Well,
the Internet side of it,
it's really different.
It's diametrically opposed.
It's like the econ before Pat Robertson or af during the background.
Subliminal.
He's under my desk right now.
Can we do it like hungry?
Eat Popcorn?
Pat Robertson just came out and said that marijuana should be legal.
It's then amazing.
Makes you want to stop smoking pot.
That's what was it?
ABS like?
He's crazy though.
We knew he was,
we knew he was crazy before he even ran for president,
and now he's like,
a pot should be legal.
It's like the Christians are sitting there going,
you know,
I can deal with rush calling that Georgetown law student a slut,
but pod legal,
you know,
or he's just gone so crazy that he's saying he completely went around like that
dude.
Then,
uh,
what was that movie with the mathematician?
Brilliant madness.
Is that what it was?
Brilliant mind.
Brilliant mind,
brilliant mind.
Remember that he worried,
he learned,
turned around,
turned around and became sane,
but so crazy became sane.
Anyway,
go to Joburg and.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight entering the code.
Ne Rogan save 15% off the number one sex toys for men.
You know,
if you're buying a a sex,
do I for yourself?
What you're looking for is to say 15% and yet the number one you want.
I don't know that everybody else is fucking as well.
You don't want to be a trailblazer.
And then the sex toy world.
You want to know?
This is the one that's,
people bought it again.
Yeah,
they get,
you get like a six pack of them.
Bloggers doesn't have a Baker's dozen.
We're also sponsored by [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t,
makers of alphabet.
It's a cognitive enhancing sub supplements.
I got entropic.
I got a new catchphrase for on it by the way.
I go for it.
Get up on it.
You remember like that olds that get up on it,
grab it like you want it?
I don't even remember that,
but I don't remember liking it.
The same people that did
back off or had a headache off.
No.
What does it,
what was that?
Was that something to cure hangovers?
Do you guys know what I'm talking about and was like go remedies.
Yeah,
it was a nerve boat,
but it was,
it was.
It was a,
that sounds like it's a real,
well,
what will the Alpha brain is,
is a,
it's a nootropic.
Nootropics are,
is there a certain vitamins and nutrients that have been proven to have a
benefit on thinking on,
on,
on the way?
Yeah.
And
then your brain's production of neurotransmitters.
It's a very controversial science.
And,
uh,
we're actually running,
I'm a part of the company,
we're running double blind placebo.
I always thought the diversity of biologist,
no nothing.
I can't even,
can't even repeat what they say correctly.
I fucked that up.
But the guy who,
uh,
I'm working with is organizing this whole thing.
What it is,
is there's a,
there's a bunch of different vitamins and not just our company.
I always tell people,
if you're interested in,
in this stuff at all,
just please Google the word nootropic and read all the pros and cons.
And it's,
it's fascinating stuff,
but essentially it's not gonna kill you.
It's vitamins for your brain.
And you know,
like a lot of things,
some people have weird allergies and some people have weird reactions to certain
things.
Some people die if ate peanuts,
you know,
the human body's not called the same people.
Is that what it is?
Does that how you feel about it?
You are blonde,
they wouldn't died.
They wouldn't have made it through little house on the prairie.
I mean,
you know a lot of people weren't making it through there.
But like if you're allergic to peanuts,
it is a sad one.
I don't want to alienate the peanut allergic people.
I looked at people they were allergic to wheat.
That's,
that's really common apparently.
Yeah,
it's you know,
it's,
yeah,
it's like what's next?
I'm allergic to air.
There was a movie about that boy in the plastic bubble or something.
That little hamster ball.
So I'm just trying to get through here.
I'll keep on a.com
is the website go there.
All the answers to all your questions about all this shit is there.
There's a bunch of different supplements that they sell.
There is not just Alpha brain but shroom tech sport,
which is the uh,
the endurance supplement,
a shroom tech immune,
all this stuff.
It will be answered at,
on it.com and if you enter in the code name Rogan,
you save yourself 10% all right bitches.
We have a specialist
Sunday,
Sunday.
Remember those
monster truck guy?
Not to be confused with Strip club Dj guy there,
their cousins,
right.
I think they're related a little bit.
Is that the music we you in it commit didn't barely commit.
We operate in the background.
I don't know what the hell that was.
Ghost train by day Joe Rogan podcast.
You did it again with the reverb.
You fucking freak.
Strange man.
This Brian red band,
very odd character.
Unlike Jim Gaffigan.
Looks like a serial killer sitting behind.
Well,
we just got back from a tie.
We just got back from a music video.
He never dresses like this.
Never.
We both music video.
Yeah.
We both usually dress like children.
Yeah,
children.
Yeah.
We were in the back row.
It was a bar scene.
Brian and I were holding hands and dancing.
Slow dancing.
Not really.
Now we're thinking about doing that,
but there were like,
no,
maybe you should just practice it.
It comes up.
I ain't,
come on.
Come on man.
Come on.
Lens.
Lie Down and cuddle the,
there's like a scene where we're supposed to cuddle.
How many guys do you want to be an actor or not?
Listen to want to be an actor.
You gotta be ready 24,
seven to act.
You do I want you to act like you want to suck my Dick.
I mean,
not in a gay way.
I have to look at pictures of myself confusing.
Right?
Yeah.
He's constantly doing that.
That's what the American public sees right now.
Jim Gaffigan,
is it also international?
Uh,
yeah.
The world gets it.
The world.
We're not douchey.
We don't keep our friends overseas from getting the feed.
No.
Communists are watching this though.
Well,
we would hope that there,
they would learn something from this.
Jim Gaffigan,
maybe I'll come out of their shell.
You remember if you ever watched that?
A,
what was it?
Uh,
was it the Robert Deniro who starred in that movie about communism in the,
in Hollywood in the 1950s and how crazy it was.
Did you ever see that movie?
I think I,
I think I know what you're talking about.
It was during the McCarthy era where they were just accusing everybody being a
catalyst.
Yeah.
Yes.
And that was kind of like,
that's what prompted the play,
the crucible,
which was the witch hunt.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Right?
Yeah.
It's kind of hard to believe that that existed,
you know,
just,
I mean,
in 1950 so it's really not that long ago they were like,
but on after communists events,
I don't think that,
I think that's happening all the time.
There's just larger examples of it.
You think like blackballing you see happening all the time?
Is that what you mean?
Fit?
We have a tendency to a a paranoia I sure do.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
definitely.
You know the,
you know,
the Arabs in this country or Muslims had to go through some shit because I think
right after nine 11 people were like,
Huh,
you're,
I mean,
I'm not talking about just the idiot.
Like Sikhs had to go through a lot of shit.
Yeah.
Guys who are Indian,
they have a real problem.
I mean,
it's so ignorant.
It's like you're not even talking about the same continent.
You silly people.
I know,
I know.
It's,
I dunno,
it's,
I,
I didn't deal with any of that.
Skated right through didn't,
I didn't deal with any,
not even a little nothing,
but people didn't even know.
They didn't think I was Muslim at all.
Yeah.
Do you think that there's a backlash?
Should be a Muslim?
I don't think there is if you're like,
I think if you were like a Muslim act,
like it wasn't there like a Muslim act on lost and it was kind of a cool part of
his personality really.
I remember that was like kind of a cool part of his personality.
Like I think there's been representation,
so I think for sure the majority opinion is people are scared,
jihad is suicide bombers,
all that stuff.
But I think more now than ever,
you get a little bit of a positive perspective on,
on uh,
on Muslims and Arabs.
No,
not,
they're not,
you can't call him the same thing.
Like the guy from lost,
like he was like,
it was a positive character is a bad ass.
My,
well,
he played a guy who tortured people in Iraq.
He's a bad ass.
I'm still liked him.
I liked the really interesting story,
but he did like tortured and killed people.
It was fascinating how that was like a part of his life and that she was shamed
by it,
you know,
later,
and it really fucked with them.
That was,
that was a great character.
That was amazing.
Yeah.
That was a great character.
That mood,
that show was for the longest time,
one of the greatest shows of all time.
The end.
I didn't really get at the end of it if it seemed like everybody was just
walking through the motions.
The last few episodes I quit shot.
Yeah.
Oh,
I thought you said
no one watched it.
Paid for it on iTunes.
Yeah,
I did as well.
I even have the DVDs,
which I never bought.
I got the blue rays.
It's the greatest,
one of the greatest shows of all time,
but no matter who you are,
I'm going to get how creative you are when you're doing a crazy fucking show
where people were allowed to travel back in time and do all kinds of nutty shit
from this magical island.
It doesn't even exist when you're doing something like that.
And after a while,
man,
you got to run dry.
It must be exhausting trying to think of nutty shit that you're going to do on
this fucking island.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's gotta be amazing to also kind of tie it together with some semblance of
logic.
All right,
so we're going to go back in time.
What would happen if we went back in time but we still want that one character
in there.
So they had to Deb weird shit to like remember they had polar bears in the
beginning and then they stopped having polar bears.
Yeah,
they just disappeared right there.
Was that that foot that had like four yeah,
the statue.
And then they started going forward in time member when Jack like had a beard
and they were sitting on that bridge and they were like,
what happened?
Great God damn show.
Especially considering it head to operate within the parameters of an ABC
primetime show.
It's insane.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
I Dunno how
I got the hardest job in the world.
I don't think shows like that really would have a shot.
Yeah.
You know,
homelands.
A good show.
I gave up after lost.
You did.
You just don't watch television.
I don't watch anything on the show.
Ended real through your flat screen out the window.
Elvis to TV.
I uh,
I only watch,
that's it.
I'm done throwing and watch.
It's not a good thing.
It's not any virtue.
Like watch bigfoot hunter.
I watched fucking two episodes.
I had DVRd fid,
hunter finding big foot or something.
And it's like a series where they have like more than one episode.
The first episode they'll be like,
yeah,
we're not going to find them.
Well,
it's tough.
No.
The best part about it is the beginning of the guys I've been hunting Sasquatch
is for 25 years,
I'll quit now.
Quit.
Quit now you haven't even got a video of one and crazy ass.
Hell was like,
you know,
it's like,
hey,
you know,
those go shows are really not realistic.
Like they never really find a ghost if we did it with that.
What's next?
Like Tuba cobre sure.
If they can sell it,
they would,
they would have it.
It's a,
it's a fun show to watch though because it's so stupid.
I mean,
first of all,
everyone has a video that they want you to analyze.
It may have been a Sasquatch,
so they to recreate the scene in the video.
It looks,
it looks so silly because the people knew exact where the car was and this is
the tree.
And so they line it up on the camera and then they have this big guy named Bobo
who kind of looks like a big foot and he goes out there and he does exactly
what,
and he's always way bigger than the big foot in the video.
So it always proves that it wasn't really a big thing as what I do right now.
Oh,
I see here you were big foot yet I was pig foot a,
season one and season two they replace me.
There was like a contract.
I want it to make us more empathetic.
And Harry and the Hendersons like a whole family lived with bigfoot.
You know,
why not?
She imagined herself.
These are my kids.
I'm pretty sure.
I don't even trust dogs that I don't know.
This guy's gonna fucking big foot hanging out with his kids.
He probably told these stupid humans a thing or two about love.
I hurry and the Henderson,
there's never been a real good big foot movie.
How about that?
Nobody has ever stepped up and it's not like
the bar's been set that high.
The bar is incredibly low.
The bar is all fraudulent videos.
That's the closest thing to a big foot movement I would've think after like
season one there's a lot of people that watch the show and they're like,
why not?
Like I think you should submit
them.
There's ever been,
there's,
I mean there was a like this is a really bad ones in the 70s or some swamp
thing,
monster guy,
but there's never been a movie,
a good movie about a bunch of people that encounter big foot.
Why?
How is it possible that you have such a a folklore that it's completely
permeated society?
He's not that no one's ever made not sexy.
I made a movie about finding bigfoot.
That's amazing.
That's true.
That's incredible.
We're really,
when you think about how popular it is,
you would think that movie would be humor.
The movie ideas they're doing,
they're just,
it's like based on a matchbook.
Yeah.
Like you'd think they'd have big photo romantic comedies.
When you hear some romantic comedy premise and you're like,
what?
I don't understand.
Finally meet again at 16.
I sometimes feel like I just established consciousness when I was like 30
because like romantic comedies,
like I,
you know,
I was so dumb I think in my twenties that like when,
it'd be like,
uh,
you know,
Meg Ryan and Billy crystal,
like Harry met Sally.
Like to me that one's just a movie.
I didn't consider that a romantic comedy,
which it was,
but now it's like this genre that is always existed,
but they just kind of like,
just churn out these,
just like those didn't exist.
It's romantic code existed.
Movies where when a woman got mouthy,
the man gave him the back of her hand back of his hand.
Right.
That's what they used to do to the moon.
Alice.
Yeah.
All that stuff.
That was really good old days.
Billy Crystal fucked us.
Billy Crystal fucked up,
fucked us in the area.
He tried be,
he tried to be manly.
They tried to like be the best.
Oh,
that example.
And then he caved that or sleep disturbance because I see,
so you see when Harry met Sally,
Harry met.
Sally is like,
it's like a sad ending to you.
You're like,
you know what?
You're like hip.
There you go.
The relationship seems like so much work.
I'm never happy with the relationship.
That seems like so much work works out cause I don't buy it.
I'm not buying it.
I'm saying she gets going to last you guys.
There's a lot of people in relationships.
You just think that they're all acting.
You're like,
wow,
no one cared this.
Everyone has been in good and bad relationships.
That's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying when you,
when one is a battle,
one is a crazy battle of payment.
Sally.
Oh yeah,
no where they have nothing in common.
It's like we hate each other.
We don't get along.
But we got drunk one night and made out.
So maybe we should get married is akin to the point.
Uh,
you know,
I'm 44.
How old are you?
21.
You look great.
These are getting to a point where you look at like older married folks and you
know,
like that,
that are just barely into each other,
barely can communicate with each other and you look at it and you go,
I could see how that can happen.
I Dunno not,
I don't yet see how it can happen.
Right.
There's nothing normal about what,
uh,
we do your,
I mean like I think at some of those married couples,
it's like I do everything with my wife.
So it's not as if,
you know,
the,
the conversation where like there's science silent man.
Like,
don't talk to me,
Virginia,
you don't like where they don't let your wife talk cause that we try and say
I'm,
you know,
yes.
On Tuesday she's allowed to talk.
No,
but there's that complete communication back breakdown.
I Dunno.
That's the only reason to be married,
in my opinion.
The only way you should ever let me other than children.
And that'll of course kind of goes with the whole package.
If that sort of relationship that like it really intense relationship that's
homophobic of you.
Thank you.
But the only reason why you should be,
you know,
is because you feel like that that's it.
And if you don't,
if it's anything less,
it's not easy.
I know.
It's definitely money.
Get your own shit.
This is a,
this is too hard.
But that's what horse before.
That's why,
of course.
No,
that's what,
you know,
you gotta suck it up.
You got to go long term.
You know,
it's like standup comedy,
you know,
I don't know.
Maybe you probably did.
All right.
But you know,
a lot of nights where you just eat,
oh I eat there.
But your commitment,
you've made the commission.
Remember when,
yeah,
that's terrifying.
Quit,
quit comedy.
And they'd be like,
I'm quitting.
And you'd look at them and he'd go,
I don't think I could ever quit.
I mean,
I really feel that way.
It's like,
this is not something like,
you know,
I'll try this.
And then maybe I'll try archery.
It's like,
it's not like I had a choice in this.
It's like I,
I was resigned to be like the weird old uncle.
I didn't think that when you're constantly making people laugh,
like you are like,
did you even just,
we're having this,
all the three of us,
there's that feeling that you get when you laughing really hard.
It's something we,
all of our brains,
like we're,
it's just like a real energy that goes off when you're really laughing hard at
something.
People fucking love that.
You love it.
They love it.
You love to do it.
It's one of the most fun things to be able to do,
to do that to a whole room full of people,
people to go out and see it.
It's one of the most fun things for them to see.
Why would you,
why would you quit?
What are you doing?
It's,
it's an absolute heroin,
right?
Going on and being able to,
you know,
make,
uh,
a crowd laugh or just coming up with a new joke.
And by the way,
I feel like it's also a responsibility because there's Jim Gaffigan fans out
there and you got them addicted to Jim Gaffigan humor and you've got to keep
coming.
You've got to keep showing up,
you've got to keep touring,
you got to keep coming to them.
They want to come see you again.
It's also,
you know,
even though I think fan is,
I mean I that that's a different to weird word.
I think it's a weird word particularly for me,
but I think it's also really important to like do well you're,
I mean,
not,
sorry.
Well,
you know,
with,
if,
if people are paying 30 bucks,
it's like they better leave.
Like if they don't leave going,
that was great.
Yeah,
you're fucked up.
Some of my most inspirational moments in comedy have been from reading a review
of someone who said that like,
oh,
I thought it was boring or I didn't like it.
You know?
And I've,
I've read those before and even if you know,
it's just one douche bag,
like sometimes it just makes you like,
just that anybody could think like that.
I have to stop that.
And you can,
you might not like the subject matter.
You might.
But if anybody thinks that it wasn't a good show and then I need to fix whatever
the fuck that is.
It's interesting because there's also,
there's the new material police.
Yeah.
Which is hard in the,
which is kind of,
it's,
it's painful but it's also good.
It's kind of like,
you know,
people are like wow,
like 75 79% of the show was new,
you know,
and then there's some people like you could do like a,
45 minutes new and do like 15 minutes old and they're like,
it was all old material.
And you're like,
what about the first 45 minutes?
People will definitely do that.
And I like hearing like Joey Diaz has some jokes I could hear over and over and
over again.
I want to hear some,
like when I go to see a guy and you know,
he's a guy that I would seen over the last year or two.
I don't mind seeing those jokes over and over again.
I certainly don't expect and a year that he's going to have a whole new act
unless he just puts something out.
And that's the crazy when you're about to do that right now you do the same
thing.
You toss everything out and then you start fresh.
I,
you know,
yeah.
I mean when I'm in New York,
but you know,
if I'm doing a theater,
I think the most important thing is to try and make it half knew at least,
but also make sure that it's a really good show.
So there is something about like,
I don't want to,
I don't want people cause you,
like you said,
some people want to hear the old,
but is that weird thing though?
Like a week ago it was all new.
It was like 75 minutes new.
But,
uh,
and I,
you know,
I have stuff that I didn't put in this,
like maybe 20 minutes.
So I'll start over with that 20 minutes and kind of throw stuff out.
But like when I'm doing a show,
it's like,
it's got to be boom,
it's gotta be both.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
You got a lot of people come and see you live though.
Mine might be like boom.
Yeah,
but I love,
I think,
I'm sorry,
I'm not going to let you talk.
But I think that that's what's so amazing about,
you know,
like we're making each other laugh here,
but like that's some of why podcasts are so fun.
It's like comedians want to talk to other comedians.
We just don't have the opportunity.
And so,
you know,
getting the opportunity to do something like this,
you're like,
well yeah,
no,
I'd love to talk to Joe.
You know what I mean?
And you were so nice cause I asked to do it that I'm really excited that you're
doing the you're special the same way Louis Ck did it.
You're going to release it completely,
uh,
on the Internet with the same price.
I think Louis kind of established it,
right?
Five bucks.
I'm going to do the same thing.
Yeah.
I think it's,
it's uh,
you know,
Louise not the first person to sell something on the Internet,
but I think he figured it out.
A real simple thing.
It's like you keep it as cheap,
you keep it cheap.
$5 is not going to kill anyone and then you keep,
make it really easy to buy and then you're just honest and a good,
you know,
people were looking forward to seeing Louis stuff cause,
and you know,
Louise is the guy that in my opinion is the,
the most prolific I think.
I don't think there's anybody as prolific as him every year,
a whole new hour and a half or whatever the hell it is.
It was whole new show.
I did a show with him in,
uh,
Boston like two weeks ago and he,
this is going to freak you out.
I'm,
I'm not sure about this,
but I,
I'm pretty positive.
He goes,
yeah,
I was writing material and I need 45 minutes for my show for those,
the comedy section of his show.
And I'm sitting there going,
wait a minute.
So he,
that 45 minutes that he's written for his show for is eight or 10 episodes or
whatever of that show,
that 45 minutes isn't even going to be part of his next hour,
which he'll do probably in two months.
Really?
How,
you know what I mean?
God,
I mean I'm not in two months,
but I think he does an hour a year.
So that's,
I heard that and I was like wow.
Yeah.
He must just put himself in weird situations to make things happen that are
funny to talk about a certain point in time.
We just start driving a bad neighborhoods,
going to massage powers.
You don't even want to be at every book on premises,
anything.
Cause I talk a lot about food and I feel as though I,
there's no more food I I've talked about.
It's like yeah,
I have a theme of animals that can kill you.
I'm always fascinated,
terrified by animals that can kill you.
How many tiger drugs could I do so
I can listen to you talk about lean pockets all day though.
Cause I am a huge,
I like,
I eat more lean pockets.
Well I do lean because I was dying.
I seriously eat it.
I eat like four weeks.
Like I,
it's way,
it's simple.
It's so easy.
You know it's not good for you.
That's the blessing and the curse of hot pockets.
Right.
Is it changed my life that,
that joke hopefully,
you know it was a whole beyond the pale was good but it's like that hot pockets.
It's a blessing.
Right?
It's,
it's opened up so many opportunities yet,
you know,
me walking through the airport,
people yelling hot pocket is not my favorite thing.
Right.
I mean I don't even know how to respond to it.
Do you get discounts for the coupons and they send you a note but when I,
I used to have theater shows and they used to have a guy dressed as a hot pocket
standing outside passing out coupons or coupons and the hot pockets for hot
pockets.
That's awesome.
Wow.
Pete you like make a deal with,
you know,
people thought that I was in cahoots with them and I was like,
I had to like send a letter.
Like you guys can't do that.
You gotta pay me.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
you don't want to be associated.
We don't want to food product feed the hot pocket thing,
you know?
Yeah.
You don't want people actually buying hot pockets and having fucking heart
attacks on your behalf right now.
One thing to crack jokes about it,
you're doing the special when you get done with it or they released it on the
Internet.
Same Way.
And Are you going to start from all,
all new?
Yeah.
You can start scaling stage.
They're just going to get,
well,
the Ice House here in Pasadena has an annex room.
It's like an 85 seat room.
Yep.
And uh,
we,
we've been doing a lot of shows there and it's like the best place ever for
fucking around and coming up with new shit.
Oh,
real.
It's really small.
It's super intimate,
feel relaxed and you know,
and they kind of know that that's what we're doing.
So we have these podcast shows where we do all the comics will come and sit
around and do a podcast and each one will go on stage and then come back and
that could be greener cat.
Wow.
Yeah.
But it's a real green room.
I mean it really is us right before we go on stage and there's like,
you know,
you see like how much time I have left.
He's a,
he's on now.
He,
Oh shit,
I got to go ladies.
Gentlemen.
Thank you very much.
Boom.
And guys will leave and they'll come back in and you know,
Hey Joey Diaz just returned.
How other other fucking fantastic.
And then he'll start talking about the show and you've got to do it.
Oh,
that's fun.
It's really fun.
You can have a different interp you might have different interpretation of the
audio.
Yeah,
well yeah,
there's definitely that.
And there's also,
when you come back here,
just like this party going on,
you know,
there's all these people and like Russell Peters came by with like fucking 10
people with them.
It's like,
it's always something crazy like that.
So it's like,
it's like a fun,
it's a fun environment and the shows are amazing.
And to me it's like I'm just going to concentrate and doing a lot of those
shows,
like really small shows and I have a bunch of ideas that I have in like fleshed
out yet.
I'm just going to ask.
Nice.
Chuck them in there and see what's up.
Little kernels.
Do you feel like the podcast is influencing your act?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Well,
it also changed my audience entirely.
My audience at one point was like a combination of fear factor people,
which were fading away and it was mostly like UFC fans.
It was like kind of curious and then,
you know,
it was still,
half of them knew what I was doing,
but now it's 100% and now it's like literally 90 to a hundred percent of the
audience is all podcast fans.
So they know you 100% they know you like as as as much as anyone could.
No,
that's fine.
Yeah.
Huge savings.
Huge.
Especially women.
Tall ones.
Lumberjack women.
Yeah.
You're not,
you're not describing the Tizen bothering me.
You're like,
hey man,
I'm open to anything.
It's all depending on what kind of situation I'm in at the time.
Do you think there's a guy out there that just goes after like the [inaudible]
of course course.
There's,
there's people that like everything man.
You know,
there's a broad spectrum.
You,
you've met people that,
you know,
you look at what their view men,
people,
I've,
I've met a few people,
kind of seven,
11 west Hollywood.
The shouldn't have went there.
That was too easy.
You ruined the vibe of the room.
I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to bring up the campuses.
He's talking about gay neighborhoods and Hollywood is at West Hollywood.
The guests want to gay as part of the world.
Pretty much.
We were in Compton today and that,
like,
I was thinking Compton like,
oh my God,
we have to get a competent.
It's just scary.
And it was like nice there.
Yeah.
Well the part where we were at was not the,
where people live over in there in an industrial chief.
He's singing about going total street just for the crud.
I'm actually from Compton,
Su,
uh,
main street,
main street company street,
right next to the reservoir.
Rosa Parks Avenue,
right in Corner Compton.
We were in a honey honey music video.
Honey honey is this band that,
uh,
we just found out about like a couple of weeks ago and they were like one of my
new favorite bands and I went to see them performing their lag,
got to meet them,
and then they came into the podcast and they were fucking amazing and just
really cool people and really,
really talented.
And so Brian and I were in a music video,
just super awesome to meet Jason Ritter was there.
And so the whole afternoon I just got to sit down and hang out with Jason writer
and I'm a huge John Ritter Fan,
so it's just so fucking weird.
And I'm sitting there,
that's the guy that was on a,
that one she's talking event three event or what's like,
he was like one of the nicest guys.
You ever work with them?
Yeah,
I did news radio with him.
He did a couple episodes and his radio.
He was great.
It was nice.
Yeah.
Super,
Super Nice Guy.
Yeah,
that,
that one was like that when a guy like that dies,
you're like,
wow,
really?
Really?
Yeah.
It's like 50 or something like that.
That affected me more than any celebrity death.
Like,
like all the other celebrity.
It's like,
I don't know that person that,
yeah,
it sucks that they're gone,
but for some reason I still think about that.
John Ritter all the time.
I would say that was up there,
but Phil Hartman doused it for me.
That was the craziest one and that's crazy.
Well,
yeah,
John Ritter was hilarious.
It was a really funny guy offstage too.
Like in between takes,
did you ever do anything with them?
Yeah,
I did a,
an episode of
Ellen Second Sitcom with him.
Uh,
and he was like a really nice guy.
It's so interesting,
you know,
like the,
that the actors that when we were kids,
you know what John Ritter was like,
uh,
I don't know who to compare him.
He was like the Jerry Seinfeld when we were like,
kids,
wasn't that,
he was pretty huge and uh,
such a nice guy,
great guy.
You know who was,
who was the guy who the director,
he was in Starsky and Hutch and now he's a director.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Uh,
God dammit.
J eat well,
he's the guy who is his wife,
I believe.
Died of AIDS.
Really?
Yeah.
God,
I can't remember his name.
Can you find that Brian?
Just Starsky and Hutch,
the,
the movie or the TV show brother.
Just a TV show.
The TV show.
Not the movie with Ben Stiller.
Not The new one.
The old one.
When I was a kid,
I fucking love this show.
Started saying hot.
Yeah.
And then one day Christy and Hachi,
you seem like you could be a character on stairs.
Started skiing so much.
Really?
No.
You know what I mean?
No,
cause it's,
that was back in that seventies era,
you know,
like,
um,
who was,
uh,
Peter Falk?
He was one.
Yeah,
Colombo.
And then there was an Beretta.
I mean,
there was like the,
the fat guy called Jack.
What was the fat guy?
That was the detective.
It was a little later,
fat guy,
Jake and the fat man.
[inaudible] the fact that guy,
you know,
like that's the,
that was the last TV show for like fat people for fat people,
you know,
that was it.
They're like,
sorry,
you know what,
Dennis France,
come on and you can get an Emmy.
But like the guy was a lead and he,
you know,
Dennis France was just like a regular looking guy.
But that Guy Jake and the fat man,
the lead character was a big fat guy.
Remember Samo Hung?
He had a sick,
he had a show on CBS with Arsenio Hall,
I think it was a fat Kung Fu guy.
Beat everybody up.
Do you remember that brand?
No.
God dammit.
I can't remember the name of the show,
but yeah,
he was a,
uh,
it was like a legit Kung Fu movie star,
but he was fat and uh,
he could like throw kicks and head kicks in.
Did you do everything?
But he was a fat guy and he would fuck guys up.
Right.
I wonder what he's doing.
But he was a fat guy.
That also is the fact Gig.
He had a good solid TV.
You know,
it's,
there's like,
you know,
I would be considered like a severely obese person on TV,
right?
Well,
I guess the biggest loser,
there's big people on that,
right?
There's a very big people on the biggest loser,
but there's a,
there's like the,
the emphasis on attractive people in movies and television is,
it's like,
it's not like disproportionate,
it's like ridiculously disproportionate.
Right.
But when you need a,
a character guy,
we need the Wacky,
you know,
uh,
what,
what does the dude's name like Steve Buscemi character or something?
So,
you know,
movies,
he'll do that.
[inaudible] I saw I was at the gym once and uh,
and I saw,
uh,
I think it was an episode of bones was on,
and again,
I don't,
I don't know the show.
I'm sure it's a good show,
but literally the,
the show was,
you know,
like when you're on the plane and there's a TV show playing and you just got to
watch it and you don't have your phone,
you don't have your headphones on.
And from what I could tell,
it's they went,
you know,
the attractive couple and then they,
uh,
someone dies who happens to be an attractive woman and then they go to a
restaurant that I think I put my headphones in and it was,
it was it,
it was in the by you.
Okay.
I don't know if the show is set in Louisiana or not,
but it was in the [inaudible] and the guy who was the owner of this authentic
alligator by u bar had my accent and he was,
he looked like he should be hosting,
uh,
the local news.
Right.
He did not.
He did not look like if you've been to Louisiana,
the people in Louisiana,
I mean,
I'm a white trash guy.
It's like,
you know,
that's funky genetics,
it's just like,
people don't like where I'm from.
People don't wear,
they wear sweatpants on Saturday night,
you know what I mean?
Right.
When they go up because they're not working.
Harry Connick is this,
Harry Connick is not the norm.
And so anyway,
so like I watched the show,
I kind of give up and hopefully this is worth it.
So then I uh,
I watch it and it's just like everyone is,
I think there are FBI agents,
everyone is like 27 like the oldest person was like 28 and they're like,
no,
you've been here a year longer than me.
It just was very interesting that there was,
there was no one like 60 there was no one like 12 it was just everyone was the
same.
2011 there was,
there were the same age.
They,
there were the same size.
Like all the women were thin and all the guys were kind of,
you know,
like workout too at times a day kind of worked out body end.
There was no one that 27 years of age is a really pivotal moment for a woman's
sexuality.
Very,
very important.
You know why?
Because at 20 she doesn't know what's going on.
You're taking advantage of a little child and you know,
at 37 she's like probably Desperado for relationship,
wants to settle down immediately.
Only has a few eggs left.
27 is like just old enough so that you're,
you're not,
you're not innocent anymore.
You're a dirty bitch,
dirty bench and you want science Dick,
you know,
that's a 27 year old girl.
That's like really the perfect time.
Perfect time to fuck you.
Just increased your
pod,
a podcast audience,
female demographic saying that explaining.
Well,
I don't know.
I think it's like
if you simplify and generalize women,
well is there a broad term like that?
These were brought up time.
Not Saying all women are bulls.
Jim Gaffigan,
Telco,
captain.
Save a hoe on me buddy.
I'm just trying to make a common example.
The women's Alliance and is the founding member of nobody would like women to be
nice more than me.
Nobody would root for them to be awesome.
More than me.
Nobody's happier than when women are nice more than me,
but nobody likes to be or hates to be told what to do by a woman more than me.
I don't like that.
Or like bossy women especially like aggressive,
aggressive,
bossy women.
Is there anything more uncomfortable when a woman gets aggressive and bossy with
you,
it's like,
oh,
this is so dangerous.
Like is going to hit you with something so you don't like strong women.
Not that I don't like bossy aggressive women.
I like strong men,
but I don't like bossy aggressive men either.
There's something almost seems like,
Oh this stupid fuck,
you can't even help it.
It's in his nature.
But aggressive woman to me is always like,
oh my God,
what are you doing?
You're,
you're like,
you're,
you have no brakes.
You're just driving crazy and you have no brakes.
Yeah.
It's interesting because there's a difference between like being a nudge and
being confident.
Yeah.
Well there's a difference between,
um,
you know,
uh,
being assertive and being aggressive and confrontational in an unrealistic way.
And whenever anybody does side,
it's always uncomfortable.
But it's,
for me,
it always freaks me out when,
when women get like aggressive and crazy.
Like when a woman starts screaming at the guy and putting her hands in his face,
I'm like,
Whoa,
what are you doing?
Like this is new.
This is almost physical violence here.
You are instigating this right,
but this ain't gonna end well.
This is crazy.
Like I bet if we had a fight like all the men versus all the women,
we would kick the shit out of them.
Most likely we would do.
We would totally,
you know like,
I mean I might get beat up,
but you wouldn't.
I think I would get beat up eventually.
Is this enough of them?
I think there's 51% of the population and that 1% means a lot.
If it was like a lot of chicks around you and when you're talking about millions
of people,
that 1% can be pretty substantial.
There's some guys that were just like,
that's their fantasy.
Yes.
To get beat up by everybody knows the one guy that has every relationship he's
ever in.
The woman's in control and she yells at him and tells him what to do and he's
always miserable.
It's a terrible situation.
Everybody knows that guy though,
right?
Everybody?
Yeah,
it's country.
But I wouldn't want to be a woman and to have a country man either.
You know,
just the only reason why I feel this way is because I'm a man and I've seen so
many guys get their lives ruined by women who probably don't even,
they probably can't even help what they're doing.
And the reason why I say this is because I had an ex girlfriend and she always,
she was a very nice person.
She liked to fight and she just loved it.
She would just start a fight for no reason.
And I'd be like,
what are we doing?
Come on,
this is crazy.
And after awhile we became friends,
but we,
we stopped dating.
And so she started dating another guy and was going through the same thing with
screaming them and yell at him and,
but this guy would just take it,
he would just eat it.
And so we had a conversation one day and she's smoking a cigarette and shaking.
She's like,
I can't help it.
She goes,
I have to test him.
She goes and when he lets me walk all over him,
I just want to fucking,
I want to scream loud enough so that he turns me around and tells me to stop so
that he brings me back to normal and tells me to stop.
I'm like,
you might be the craziest fucking person on the face of the earth.
Like imagine living your life like that.
What a bitch.
She's not a bitch.
She's just compelled by her own genetics to not have a bitch for a man.
You know,
she,
she was like,
oh well wild horse.
He needed to be broken.
Jim Gavin
talking about she did.
Yep.
Are you still doing Pale force?
Nope.
No,
I haven't done that for God.
In a sense.
Conan had a Fallon's was pale force pill force was where it was an animated
thing that actually my brother in law,
um,
Paul knows who's a cartoonist for the New Yorker.
He came up with this idea of an animated series where Conan,
I would,
we're superheroes that would fight crime with our paleness and sweet.
We would shoot lasers from our nipples is awesome.
And it's the art style.
Did he do that then?
They did all that.
Did he do the Saturday night live?
A Fun House?
The videos.
That's my goal.
That's right.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I loved it.
I think,
I thought it was a lot of funny.
She could do that more.
Yeah.
I think while NBC owns it and me,
NBC and Conan,
I don't know if they're a net good of,
oh,
that's right.
Oh yeah,
Yeah.
Dating Barrett and they can't even do that.
What a mess.
That whole thing.
One of the masses.
Right.
So crazy.
Just the whole idea was crazy.
Putting the Jay Leno show on at 10 like what you're going to have the tonight
show on.
I mean,
earlier when they did that,
didn't you think that that was,
I thought that was their way of like,
well,
if Joe,
if Jay fails,
then we say we give them a try.
But I think I like that.
That's what I thought.
They thought it was going to happen.
But what happened was,
because Jay was on earlier,
I killed Conan's chance to even get an audience.
So people would watch the tonight show at 10 and then they wouldn't watch it
later.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
It was ridiculous.
It was silly.
It was a silly idea.
It's where,
you know you're the comedy policemen.
No,
no,
you aren't.
She called me that before the Improv and I told you that would be very
uncomfortable.
That makes you uncomfortable.
Not really,
but I only,
I looked,
I haven't,
I'm not enjoying step in for one piece of civil unrest.
That's something I've never done anything since.
Well,
there's something about that whole situation with a Lenovo and I don't know
which eye at all and uh,
but it's,
you know,
if there was a Joe Rogan of that generation maybe to go and,
uh,
explain it,
that's why you,
that's our new show.
You look for bigfoot
comedy kind of a,
well,
I think for all of us there was a,
there's been a few instances in the past where there was a guy that was kind of
like clearly plagiarizing another guy and then you know,
one guy became famous with other people's Shit.
I mean it's happened more than once and we've all felt the real pain and
frustration of watching someone do somebody else's material where you'd know
that they're stealing,
they know in the dark,
not compensating them,
they're just,
they're just stealing and it was like a wild west thing.
It was like no one was doing anything about it and it was a,
and to treat it like it was no big deal.
You're absolutely crazy.
It's the core of someone's ability to perform on stage is having great material.
It's their life,
it's their life.
You can be the best comic in the world.
You have nothing to say on stage for that moment.
If you go on stage and you have nothing prepared and he had nothing to say,
you're fucked.
It's not going to be good.
You need premises,
you need material.
And so to,
to pretend that it wasn't a big deal,
that the industry was treating it like it wasn't a big deal.
And we were like,
this is crazy.
Like,
you know,
I think you've got an insane,
I told you that night what you did was very important.
I mean,
it was very important.
Well,
for us it had to happen.
It had gotten to a point where no one,
everyone was just turning a blind eye to it because they are profiting off of
it,
you know?
And that's what happens when a person becomes successful and,
and,
and is a plagiarist if it was any other form of art,
whether it was,
you know,
writing it would,
right.
It would be super clear.
I mean,
the guy was going to jail,
you know,
and he was music.
They take all your money if they can prove the of the same beats and you're
copying it like you're taking,
they take all your fucking money,
man.
Yeah.
And we're not talking about,
you know,
similar premises which we all have,
which is all going to happen where tiger woods who has a fucking tiger woods,
Joe put your,
raise your hand,
everyone,
anyone.
Everyone sat down and said this fucking a gold mine.
You can never claim a premise but you,
you absolutely know when,
when when the language is lifted.
Well you also know where there's smoke,
there's fire and they can't.
I think I truly believe that people who steal can't,
right.
I really do.
I think it's the,
I don't think you can do both.
I think something happens when you steal and that that this,
this being disingenuous,
this pretending,
this bullshit knowing that you are,
you are not really doing what you're claiming to be doing,
that you are pretending and that you're ripping people off and lying and
projecting this false self image which is like all ego,
which is exactly what shuts you off from the ability to come up with new shit.
Like when you come up with new shit,
it's not like you thinking about you.
You see something,
a hook of this side here.
This is what,
this is ridiculous and that,
you know what I mean?
It's not you,
you,
I mean it's you coming up,
but then you think about,
but you're not involving yourself.
You're not trying to project a certain image.
You're not,
you know,
making sure that people think of you a certain way.
You're not even thinking like that.
Because when you do think like that,
that's,
that's shuts off creativity.
And when a guy steals what a guy's doing when he's stealing is he's trying to
make himself better than he is.
He's trying to pretend that he's smarter than he is.
He's trying to put out stuff,
pretending that he figured this out when it real is really someone else.
It's all ego.
It's,
it's really sad too.
It's sad in a way because I think that it's almost as if,
you know,
like policemen,
they have like rabbis,
you know,
it's like,
I feel like almost comedian should have rabbis,
someone to sit there and go,
all right,
you know what?
You might not want to do that.
You know,
it's such a strange business and we're all very individual and,
but you know,
the,
the irony
also is,
is that any comedian would tell you that,
uh,
the respect of their peers is way more important than whether you're selling out
Saturday night.
Yeah.
That hurts guys bad when their peers turn on it's protocols,
guys back.
It's like,
you know,
it's like you,
you always heard about comedians that like,
you know,
like African American communities when they would comedians they would lose the
black audience.
I mean that's brought us,
but like when,
when Comedians,
you know,
don't respect her flaws as great for weight loss.
I heard you have no money for food.
Yeah,
yeah.
But
yeah,
um,
that,
that can be really devastating to God.
Let's talk about something that's more depressing.
No,
wait,
you mean it's,
I think what's important is like what we were talking about earlier,
we were talking about Louis C k like w when you're doing it the right way,
not just doing it the right way,
but like fucking trailblazing,
like way faster than anybody else's being,
putting out that kind of material.
And putting out great stuff.
It's not like the quality suffering.
It's still really fun.
Great observations.
And so there's a lot of thought behind.
It's like really great stuff.
So we sit here and we talk about that,
like how amazing that is.
That's,
that's the positive thing.
And I'm sure,
you know,
he gets that all the time cause that,
that's what the fuck he's doing.
You know?
And he's,
yeah,
he's,
he's got this whole momentum thing going.
He keeps turning out the great new stuff.
People keep enjoying it and it keeps moving and moving and moving.
And that's really an example for everyone to see every young comic to see that
it can be done.
It's just do it the right way.
You do it the right way.
It's incredibly satisfying.
But if you hack and,
and chop your way and take other people's premises,
man,
boy,
you're fucking,
you're not just fucking yourself up.
You're fucking him up.
You're fucking the community up if it gets tolerated,
but it becomes a real problem because I think some of the cliches you might
disagree with me,
I think,
I think like basic cliches about comedians are not true.
Like there are a lot,
you know,
like all Comedians,
Haiti.
I think actually that's actually the opposite.
I think most Comedians,
if you're getting on stage there,
you're predisposed to like the guy yes.
Or,
or a woman and Spicy Sinbad.
I don't know Sinbad,
but if I see Sim that,
I mean,
I'm not really into his stuff,
but I'd be like,
Hey,
what's up man?
How you doing?
I'm like,
hello.
It's like there's,
there's so many different types of comedy.
You're,
you're at least going to be respectful.
Of course.
You're not going to go out of your way.
I mean,
there are exceptions.
You know,
where like,
I think Larry,
the cable guy and David Cross had like a feud.
I think that was silly.
I read David's arguments about that.
I thought that was really silly.
I mean,
I think,
yeah,
Larry does have like a few,
uh,
sort of,
Islamophobic Sorta raghead jokes in his act and stuff.
But I mean,
wouldn't that,
what I mean,
he is playing a character.
Are we supposed to pretend that the character wouldn't think like that?
I get confused about that when,
you know,
the guy's name is Dan Whitney and he's doing a thing called Larry the cable guy
and this guy is supposed to be stupid as fuck and live in the south.
I see Dave's argument that it might be encouraging racism,
but I
also like,
she really did.
She do you think Larry,
the cable guy is changing anybody's mind whether it's awesome was a bad ships a,
it's a slippery slope is very slippery slope and the shit on anyone's choices
when it comes to that.
I mean,
some of the funniest stuff I've always said is the most inappropriate,
ridiculous.
Like auto and George,
you know,
like you ever seen that?
You seen that one George?
Me?
No,
no.
Are you kidding?
One of my favorites.
First got an opening spots in New York around,
you know,
and I would tank and then they would,
there would be a middle that would do okay.
And then auto and George would go up.
What year was this?
Nah,
1831 he's got something he's doing online.
Check it out.
It's called the pig roast.
I don't know the exact address,
but if you Google it,
just Google auto and George the pig roast.
I don't want,
George is a Hilarious,
a puppet act in New York and he was always like that example of a guy who would
just say to all the,
the dummy was evil as fuck.
His dummy would see the shit quotas is that people would leave and they would
say that one guy was funny,
but I thought the [inaudible] was really rude.
Oh my God.
It's like,
I know.
Yeah.
He would say some of the craziest,
most ridiculous racist shit.
And then tongue and he would still the dummy,
hey man,
you can't fucking say that and it's wrong.
And then we're like,
fuck you.
What a great gimmick.
You know,
to have a really angry,
psychotic fuck a dummy and the comedy is him.
He says fucked up shit and you go man,
I can't believe you're saying that.
That'd be what I'm not even making brilliant idea.
I can't believe he did that.
But that's,
that's a,
it's a style of comedy.
It's like death metal or they really killing people every day.
That's really,
you know,
it's a style.
It's,
it's a type of comedy.
There's,
there's uh,
you know,
and people want to say like shock comedy that it's cheap.
I so disagree cause it doesn't work unless it is funny.
I mean shock comedy won't work on me unless it is funny and there's a certain
art to writing ridiculous,
shocking shit cause there's an art to it and it's a type,
it's a genre to style shock comedy is,
it's the SL align on in the northeast.
That's where
the a seller line,
you know,
what does Amtrak,
Amtrak from Boston to DC.
There's the Slo line.
Have you ever heard?
No.
I never heard of it.
And,
um,
but that's where like,
that's where tough guy comedy comes from is like,
is like Boston,
you know,
New Jersey,
Philly,
right?
It's like that.
And that,
that Amtrak train goes up and down that.
And those are like,
those are the,
those are the tough guys.
You're a tough guy.
You know what I mean?
How did we get to this?
What were we talking about?
Well,
we're just talking about,
I dunno,
I completely lost my point.
Just made me uncomfortable.
It did.
I make you uncomfortable,
but you know what I'm talking about?
Like the,
I don't know George.
Oh,
George.
But I do enjoy angry mean comedy.
Yeah.
Not,
not necessarily mean,
but shocking.
Like,
I think in New York it was,
it was,
uh,
it was important to appear tough when I was starting out will not,
not having emotion attached.
You see that?
And Louis Louie has it and a towel has it.
And Kevin Brennan has it.
And a Marin.
I mean,
even though Marin is such an open book,
he has a little bit like being unphased by at least on stage.
Does that make sense?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You have it too.
Well,
you have to,
uh,
well you have to,
you know,
really be into what you're thinking about and if you're into what you're
thinking about,
you know,
you're not going to be really phased if people are into it or not.
You gotta you know that there's a certain number of people that are your people.
Yeah.
Especially if you're doing weird shit,
you know?
I mean,
you're really clean,
but really funny.
But do you ever find yourself in a situation where like everyone in front of you
around you is just talking about anal fisting loads and rape and then you go up
and you're like,
okay,
if you're like,
hey,
who wants to talk about cake?
What about,
well,
no,
it's you appear,
you know,
if someone's,
fucking a chair or simulated it,
that's my shit.
No,
but it's hard to go up there and go,
you know,
it's interesting to this section of the USA Today.
It's hard,
right?
Because you just appear so boring.
But if you follow,
so if you don't follow someone really filthy or kind of like crushing,
so it just crushes it,
crushes or just kind of,
uh,
just,
reverend,
you know,
just thick irreverence,
then,
you know,
it's not,
I mean,
you can do it.
It's just like,
it's different styles of comedy.
You know what I mean?
It's like if like a Metallica went on,
I wouldn't want Jane.
I sir,
I wouldn't want to be James.
Thanks.
So you're calling me James Taylor.
James Taylor is awesome by the way.
I'm a James Taylor Fan.
My mind,
he's,
yeah,
he's a bad ass.
I like James.
Yeah.
For Real.
No.
So
they let me know.
See,
I was growing up,
I remember a bad mother fucker when I was 16.
I got my driver's license.
Here's another boring story by Jim gas.
And I got my driver's license and uh,
went to a concert with,
I am the youngest of six kids,
so my brothers and sisters went to a concert,
which was the James Taylor concert.
I know that this sounds edgy already.
So I was 16.
And I,
uh,
I thought,
you know,
all you gotta do is show an ID and they'll let you have a beer.
And so I showed my idea,
I got my driver license driver's license that day.
So I showed him the ID and the guide took my idea because you're,
you're not 21.
He took the ID so I didn't have an ID.
So I got my driver's license that day.
So then the next day my dad in the morning was like,
Hey,
let me see your driver's license.
Do you know you guys?
And so then a week later my driver's license shows up male and uh,
with a letter from the guy who ran,
you know,
I know what it was,
somewhere in Chicago,
Alpine valley or whatever.
And the guy's name was James Taylor.
So like James Taylor,
I'm like James Tattooed of connected.
Yup.
It's coke.
Zeros go into my head.
You getting crazy.
I'm getting crazy.
James Taylor will do that.
It does it to women.
And occasionally the hit the estrogen genes that you have dark,
dark in the closet tucked away.
See I sang the beginning of that song and you just,
I saw you swap a little easy chair email to a little,
I have melted a little bit.
James Taylor songs are like a little back rubs like,
but that's also,
you know,
that's,
that's kind of now some of those songs.
It's like I know those songs because of it.
My,
uh,
brothers and sisters,
right.
I mean it's not like I was sitting there like I got to,
you know,
well somebody,
I was listening to you,
but did you,
did you ever by a James Taylor CD on your own?
I Dunno.
I know.
Maybe.
I don't know.
No,
I didn't buy a CD.
I have proudly,
I think I even bought up the second tier,
like a martial arts expert.
So you're allowed to say shit and people would be like,
he's still a tough guy.
I'm not going to call him a buzzy.
But you know,
like I sit there and I,
uh,
I read the New York Times and people are like,
well,
I have to beat up the librarian.
You know what I mean?
Even though I played you being self deprecating while you're reading the New
York Times that that's happened many times.
I actually played,
I was,
I played football in college.
People think I'm a pussy.
That's scary.
Football is fucking terrorists,
division three,
whatever it is,
they're big people running into your man.
That shit's dangerous.
Did you ever do any of that?
Ooh,
I wrestled in high school and my coach was always like,
we're all getting used to playing football.
Yeah.
Crazy.
You'll be great.
I wrestled in high school.
I wrestled the hundred and 34 pounds and 34 pounds.
That was the ladies division.
Yeah,
no,
that was,
I was under the ladies.
I would help them be ready.
No,
I was one 67 I remember I was undefeated my senior year.
What are you really,
you were killing wrestler one 77 again,
this is a spy school and uh,
so you know how like we didn't have tons of guys on the team.
So like I lost like 10 pounds in a week that I remember.
Like people used to do that and right.
So yeah,
I did that.
You'd lose 10 pounds to go to a different division and you would wrestle that
because there was like some big fat guy who could do mine because they didn't
have someone for that slot.
Right.
So I lost 10 pounds.
I was undefeated and then um,
you know,
I went out there and I like blacked out,
pinned,
you know,
and it was,
it was brutal because I was,
it was close to an undefeated season.
That's pretty bad ass though.
I beat the guy that was third in state.
Wow.
How come you never did anything with it afterwards?
You ever tried Jujitsu?
I,
you know,
I don't like standing up
exercise at all.
I mean,
yeah,
no,
I used to be thin,
but you know,
I'm,
I'm not talking about like back in the day,
I'm talking about like do,
do anything right now.
Do I do that?
And he won 97 or [inaudible] 96.
That's really good.
I heard it.
I've heard it works that if you just follow what this guy's doing,
it really will transform your,
it's all scientific principles still work out.
I used to,
I,
you know,
I was pretty buff.
I've watched a video of it.
It's fucking pretty intense stuff.
I try new wines.
It's,
I couldn't do it.
It's been tough.
And do you work out five days a week?
At least five days a week.
Do you have like a gym in your house?
I have two gyms in my house.
Well that's normal.
Everyone.
I have a weightlifting gym in my house and I also have a kickboxing set up all
caged in,
in my garage.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
it's a company.
Did it for rather a television show due to call garage Mahal.
It's pretty bad ass ever released that shot.
Yeah.
It's a Bill Goldberg,
that big wrestler Guy and he's the,
uh,
the host of it and they take over your garage and in three days they transformed
it.
My garage is just like an episode of drastic,
then you're kind of like,
where am I going to park my car?
No,
no,
no.
It's a four car garage.
So I have two cars,
two s club to NBC for years.
Um,
so to two cars is just pat it up.
Yeah.
Let cars,
well,
how many,
you got two cars.
I've got a few cars.
How many cars do you have,
Jay?
I have four cars.
Four cars.
Really?
And what's,
what's the,
what's your,
the love of your life car?
I have a Porsche gt three,
like the,
it's,
it's basically like a regular Porsche.
They take all the,
they like unnecessary shit out of it.
Like the back seat.
They strip all the sound deadening.
They make it lighter.
They pick up,
put a bigger,
stronger high revving racing engine in it,
tighten up to suspension,
carbon fiber,
brakes,
the whole thing.
It just becomes this most,
the most ridiculous responsive car you could ever drive.
It's like you're glued to the road like you feel like every day.
It's incredible.
Not even,
not even for driving fast,
driving illegally.
This is,
this is kind of a,
it makes me think of this point.
It's like when you started stand up,
did you think that you were,
I mean maybe I don't know you that well.
It's like I went in to stand up because I want it to,
I,
I never had an expectation that I would be able to afford to have a family from
standup.
You probably didn't expect that you'd be able to own four cars.
No,
never.
Of course,
man.
I never would have believed that I could make a living off of it.
In the beginning.
That was a dream,
a distant dream.
The great dream was to be a local Boston standup comic,
to be like a local guy.
You know,
there was a bunch of local guys that made a living.
They drove,
look at,
he's got a nice Honda Lucas.
We've got a great fucking apartment.
It's a loft as offices on the top.
Boy,
that's where he writes.
He's a pro.
I'm like,
this is a pro that gets paid to be a comic.
Sans [inaudible] likes unfathomable.
I had just had a series of shitty jobs,
you know,
and all of it.
Drove a limo.
Did construction every po delivered newspapers every possible ridiculous job.
So no,
and would have never thought I'd have four cars.
Oh,
I never thought I'd have money at all.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's weird.
It's,
it's,
well,
you know,
and I think the lesson that other people can learn always from anyone success
is,
it might not be the same path,
but if anybody can do it,
you can do it.
It really is that fucking simple.
And it might not be everything.
You know,
it might not be,
I can't play basketball.
I can't run.
I'm not a jumper.
I'm not,
I'm not fast.
You know,
it's like I'm too short.
I can't do that.
Maybe I could,
maybe if I dedicated myself 100% of that,
I mean,
it wasn't there a guy like Muggsy Bogues he was like five,
six,
he played in the NBA.
But the point is,
whatever the fuck it is,
just,
just do it.
Just go do it.
Find a way to do it.
If anybody can do it,
you can do it.
I think there's also a justing cause you know,
when you have these,
when you do like interviews,
like when you're,
you know,
touring during standup headlining and clubs,
you'll get interviewed by the local paper.
Yeah.
And they'll want to create some story,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
for a headline,
he's from Indiana.
He had no shoes.
Talk to him about cake.
You know,
it's like they,
these elaborate stories so it ends up,
you know,
it's like,
I don't even,
our stories are real stories.
Uh,
they kind of adjust.
I think when I started stand up,
I love to stand up,
but I wanted to be a writer for Letterman.
I thought that would be an unbelievable job.
And you know,
it's just,
it's an amazing,
yeah,
the journey.
Believable job.
I mean,
that's like the elite of the elite as far as comedy writers.
Like this is Bobby writes for Letterman.
Whoa,
right?
For Letterman,
Holy Shit.
And when we started,
Letterman was always the top of the,
I think right now,
I mean,
I love Letterman,
but I think Jimmy Kimmel is at least as equal.
I think Jimmy Jimmy was fucking brilliant.
I really think he's,
yeah,
I think,
well,
yeah,
Conan is always equal.
I mean,
he's always funny in his own way.
You know,
he's,
I think he's very different than those other,
those other guys.
And I think one of the beautiful things about his show was all the things that
people would go,
I'm accustomed to that they pulled from him that he can't even use now.
And I think that's really fucked up.
You know the whole,
it's so silly.
The whole thing to me it says so stupid.
What?
You can't do the talking dog anymore.
You can't do it.
You know what?
There's like a million things that he can't do anymore.
Like that's just petty horse shit.
I think that's completely patty.
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
It's a strain.
You let the show,
that's the show.
The show's over there now.
It's with colon.
Come on man.
It's is so silly.
It's very strange.
They should be able to buy it back.
If they should sell it back to them
valley and someone goes and they,
you know there are the head coach here and then,
then you go there,
he goes to another team.
You,
you,
you get something for it.
Yeah.
It's not like you're sitting there cause I think there's no,
like these coaches,
they're not supposed to be able to coach.
You know,
like if they leave they have to finish their contract of seven years or
whatever.
They're not supposed to be able to coach for the rest of the seven years.
But they do anyway.
Well that's a,
didn't that happen with radio?
With Tom Likes us.
I'll really like his had a deal with the 97 one FM talk in La and they
syndicated is
show all throughout the country and those talk radio shows,
I don't know what killed the man.
What would kill talk
because look man,
when you think about what that was,
that net network,
I believe they had Howard on in the morning,
right?
It was Howard and then it was a,
it was frosty Heidi and frank and it was like,
there was a bunch of good fucking shows.
It's like,
well how did that get,
how did that go away?
Like what?
What happened?
What killed talk radio.
Radio is just hurting in general.
These podcasts.
Nothing.
Not,
no.
I don't know.
Was cause that was before podcasts before we had ever done it.
No,
it is like this was off the air.
Yeah.
But sounded like was puck was podcasts,
but podcasts really popular when,
when like us was off the air podcast we obviously weren't doing,
but where was anybody.
Yeah,
podcasts are really popular and then it went away.
Then the iPhones Kinda came out in a,
they start,
that was pre Carolla podcast.
It was Corose still have the radio was satellite radio.
[inaudible] was the morning show.
After awhile.
Remember Howard went to Saddleback.
That's what it was.
Do people listen to in the morning in la?
Like living in New York?
He used to be awesome.
That's one of the things that I used to love the most about driving to work and
being stuck in traffic was that I was listening to Howard stern and they would
report it.
No,
he is.
He's still on regular radio.
Regular radio.
That doesn't exist anymore.
There's nobody like that anymore.
I mean there are,
there are some morning shows like Kevin and being in La,
there's still gray.
They're huge.
Right?
They're there.
The last of the Mohicans,
Carson Daly and see Chris,
don't they have shows in Hartsdale?
He has a radio show.
I thought so.
That was nice to let her know.
I know Seacrest Seacrest has like 100,000 fucking jobs.
He must be insane.
Nobody works harder than that guy who has what puts in more hours a day.
And that guy,
he's on that he show,
he's got a radio show he's on,
he's on the star search.
Whatever the fuck it is.
But it just,
let's see what the stars,
what the fuck is he on?
The big white American idol,
the big one that she was still on.
I think amazing.
There is some ideas sometimes what you're saying there is something about
people want to,
it's not greed.
It's like,
I think that,
and I don't know Ryan,
sea crest,
big surprise and uh,
but I think he,
you know,
he wants his empire.
Yeah.
I think some people want their empire and I think you recognize opportunities.
A smart gun that,
you know,
and it is very smart,
but it's maybe it's crazy.
I think it did at least a little crazy.
They didn't want to have a little fun.
Well,
and also he might just super that the only thing he's into is like
entertainment.
And might be true too.
Brian,
what are you doing with the,
the fucking thing?
You crazy asshole.
What are you doing with that effect on getting ready to go to the bathroom?
Oh,
oh,
so you're going to leave the screen like this.
Oh,
I like that.
That's very clever.
Do you feel weird?
We're,
we're right next to each other on this video screen.
Can we just talk,
look,
just,
let's look at the screen and,
uh,
let's see if we can have a conversation this way.
I bet we can.
I bet we can know how to even Janet over there.
It's too weird.
It's like I'm not the brightest guy.
It's a thing to watch yourself talk.
I don't think that's healthy.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I,
I was editing my special and you know,
my wife and I were,
and it was,
uh,
it's,
I mean,
the thing is like,
it's one thing,
it's like I'm out of shape.
It's like,
that's the beauty of like,
I'm not looking at yourself,
is not realizing how out of shape you've gotten.
Not that I was easy to look at before I was out of shape.
You're half your act as about like a little bit about self indulgence and
delicious things and gluttony.
Do you think that if you,
uh,
if you got yourself in like spiffy condition that my fuck up your material?
I've heard people say shit like that before.
That's interesting.
You know,
there was a point,
you know,
when,
uh,
about a year ago while I was doing something else,
but I thought,
you know,
I was,
I was working out because I had more time,
so I was working out more consistently and not eating horribly at three in the
morning.
Um,
and I was like,
you know,
it entered my mind.
It's like,
am I going to be too in shape for some of these jokes?
Um,
but I don't know.
That's kind of,
that's just me being neurotic crime.
Like,
can we do it shape for these children?
That's hilarious.
What a great escape clause.
I can't,
my act is so important.
I can't do sit ups.
I can't,
you know,
I work out,
but it might mess up like that third chunk is in the hour.
So stupid.
But I really believe this,
that,
uh,
I was,
getting into a meditation and I was getting into yoga and a bunch of things when
I was young.
And,
uh,
when I had first started getting,
getting into comedy and then I thought about it,
I said,
you know what,
maybe I shouldn't do this because maybe becoming more enlightened is probably
bad for my ad.
It's interesting because then I wouldn't be making fun of as many things are
picking as many victims that especially that's a comedian there.
Right.
Cause especially Boston style comedy,
so mean.
So you know,
attack it's attack style.
You know.
And I was thinking,
man,
if I became enlightened and I was all like peace and love,
like this would be terrible for my art and I'm not going to stop being a
comedian.
You know,
it might not,
I wouldn't want to eat healthy.
You know,
I think I got another hour,
I may be a healthy,
I owe my fans.
Yeah.
And then you run out of shit and then you'd go healthy and then nobody wants to
come see anymore.
Well I used to be really thin.
I mean,
I did.
I know you're looking at me like no,
you,
I believe you.
No,
no,
no.
I actually,
I remember you being thin.
Just A,
I mean,
not even a decade ago,
right?
How many,
how long ago was it?
Um,
I dunno,
eight years ago.
Who was the guy?
There was a guy who was like a really funny fat guy and then he lost a lot of
weight and then he kinda like stopped being around.
I want to say Vic,
Vic something in Vic Dunlap.
Was it very funny,
funny.
I was thinking fic Vic Dunlop,
very funny.
Really,
really heavy.
And then he lost a lot of weight or he had the surgery and the surgery.
I don't know if he did or he didn't,
but whatever,
whatever method he choose chose,
I mean,
maybe I'm
just not up on what he's doing these days,
but I remember seeing that guy everywhere when he was big.
And then,
you know,
he got skinny and you know,
don't hear about it too much now.
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's weird because we also,
if people will disappear and you don't even realize they're gone.
Yeah.
That was weird.
Right.
And it's guys that you were like that I thought that guy was going to be around
forever.
Like that.
Really funny.
It's interesting he said women,
is that getting married,
having kids,
you thought it'd be that.
It could be,
some people get tired of the stress.
You know,
Jim and I were talking about how much we love standing up.
We would never quit doing it,
but everybody's got a different psychological makeup.
And for some people the,
uh,
anxiety and performance is like really intense.
Yeah.
Especially,
it's also,
it's,
I think that,
uh,
some of it's luck.
I mean,
it's a real cruel business.
Yes.
So,
I mean,
I was definitely an angry guy,
you know,
like for a lot of people were successful before me and I was,
I was angry or bitter couple of years,
really get yourself out of that therapy.
Really.
Yeah.
Wow.
You know?
And that's,
you know,
just also I came to the conclusion that I was not doing stand up.
Uh,
you know,
I wanted,
I wanted to be,
I was happy for my friends success,
but I felt like I was a failure,
but like I had to come to the conclusion what is success and what success is,
is like doing what you love and actually getting paid for it.
And so then I adopted that attitude and then things started going my way and
that's why I'm releasing a 12 books series.
That's interesting,
man.
That's really cool.
I love hearing stuff like that.
I love hearing somebody figuring things out and just turning it all around.
A lot of wasted energy on it.
That was really a lot of wasted on haters.
I always say no haters are winners.
There's no,
no,
no.
People out there writing scathing youtube comments where they just break down
your fucking soul winners through.
You're not happy.
There's no way you are,
you wasting your energy and what are you wasting it.
Yeah.
It's also,
it's like you put out,
you get what you put out.
Yes you do.
Yeah.
And it does make you feel,
you know,
like if you're feeling shitty,
it's like,
and you help someone,
you feel better.
Yes.
Particularly if you steal from them while you're helping.
Yeah,
I dunno man.
So it's just really nice to me to see someone kind of figure things out like
that and like get a,
get a new perspective on things.
These lessons like sure.
Over and over and over.
I don't remember member who
said it,
but they said that inspiration is effective but it's like bathing.
It only lasts for so long.
That's why we recommend it daily.
Yeah.
And the idea being that,
you know,
I guess it's easy to fall into a pattern of just not,
not having your shit together and not thinking right or you know,
letting yourself get jealous or letting yourself go down a negative way.
You know,
people like this.
So this is a big cliche.
Like,
you know,
I'm just trying to keep it positive.
Just try to cute sometimes keep what really keeping it positive means is
addressing some shit that's not positive at all.
You know,
and,
and getting to know what the fuck is making you tick.
And if you find out that you're getting angry for someone else's success for no
reason,
it's like your,
your brain knows you're talented,
you like,
you know,
your telling.
But why isn't anybody else seeing it instead of your brain using that resource
and going,
let's just make sure it's undeniable.
Let's,
let's just concentrate on being funnier and funnier until no one can say shit.
Yeah,
well,
it's the ant deniability thing,
but I think also it's,
for me,
it's,
it's very much like I have to be in touch with being humble.
I know this is sounding really corny.
No,
not like,
usually when I'm angry is when I think I'm in control.
I'm somehow like,
I'm crazy enough to think that I can control the entertainment business or I can
control whether,
you know,
my flight's delayed,
that,
yeah.
That's just insane.
You know,
it's like,
well,
maybe if I'm angry to this flight attendant,
the plane will take off sooner.
You know,
it,
it doesn't make sense.
So when I'm in touch with,
uh,
you know,
being humble,
it,
it ends up paying off.
Yeah.
That's a very important part of it.
That's the 13th book of my series.
Well,
when we were talking about earlier about guys who,
uh,
went up stealing material and the,
that stealing is the opposite of being humble.
You,
you want more credit for what you've achieved,
what you've,
you know,
who you are,
what you're selling.
You want it,
you're pretending it's better than it really is.
It's the exact opposite of humility and that is the exact wrong state of mind to
be in for creativity.
I think that's,
yeah,
that's,
that's so fucking awesome that you figured that out,
man.
I,
um,
I was a for sure at certain points of time,
early in my career,
I really had a hard time enjoying comedy because,
uh,
when someone would kill you when someone was really good,
I would always thinking is,
man,
he better than me.
Fuck I in up better than me,
man.
Fuck it.
How good is that?
That guy's got a pretty fucking good,
like it bother me that something was good and I couldn't just enjoy it.
I couldn't just sit back and watch.
It took a while before I figured that out,
let it,
that that was holding me back,
that I would work with people and if they were really good I would get nervous,
you know,
instead of the way I do it now,
I bring like really funny people on the road with me on purpose because I want
to be laughing too.
Like I want,
you know,
when,
when I work with Ari Shaffir,
I don't know him and Duncan Trussell and Joey DHEAS and Tom Segura all,
he's really funny guy.
So what?
I'm sitting there waiting to go on stage.
I'm laughing my ass off and it puts me in the perfect state of mind.
Like I want them to be brilliant.
I want them to kill.
But when I was young,
I was terrified of it.
I didn't want anybody else to be in a good,
I wanted them to be terrible so that I could fucking skate by on my,
my shitty act.
Yeah.
Well,
and it's amazing how alerts
and I think it's,
I think it's insane how I think podcasts are making comedians.
Like it's,
it's siphoning out,
I mean,
I'm a joke Smith and it's,
it's adding,
um,
you know,
discourse or kind of reflection back into stand up.
Right?
Whereas it used to be like,
what's the deal with keys?
Right.
And so now it's,
I feel like,
I dunno,
maybe I'm wrong,
but you know,
it's,
it's like podcasts are influencing some of this,
you know,
it's like Pete Holmes even said that to me.
He said that his podcast is changing his act.
And I'm like,
that makes sense.
It's,
it's gotta be so fun to like when you hear a bit and then you can go,
you know what?
Cause you know,
when you hang around some friends,
you know,
like three in the morning,
you don't have someone recording it.
Right,
right,
right.
Like when you're doing a podcast and you're like,
go back to like that in the middle.
I said something funny.
That can be a bit,
that might be a bit,
Oh yeah,
I've definitely come up with some beds from the podcasts.
100% for sure.
Yeah.
I mean you're talking three hours at a pop,
you know,
many times.
We,
we've done many three hour ones.
We did a Kevin Smith one,
I think there was a longest one we ever did,
like three and a half hours.
Yeah.
That's probably the only things to Twitter to,
for reminding you.
You know,
it'd be like,
like you'll say something and be like,
Oh shit,
I did say that.
Oh I don't,
Twitter is amazing.
It's amazing.
Twitter is changing.
How,
I mean I've done things on Twitter and I remember like a year ago I did some
jokes cause we just had a kid and I was driving to do a show and uh,
the guy who was opening,
he was like,
you're going to put those in your act,
aren't you?
And I was like,
I didn't even think of that.
And he was like,
yeah.
And it's like they're great jokes.
Like,
and now like Twitter is this source of like,
is this funny?
I mean,
yeah,
99% of the time.
No,
but if you can get two great lines,
open up a topic,
well you're going to get them.
You're,
you're going to get some tweets from this podcast for sure.
Where Pete people will quit tweet quotes that you said laugh.
That happens all the time.
Right.
And you'll forget even said it and then someone will tweet it.
That's fun.
What do you,
what's your numbers now?
Would you,
what do you have the numbers?
Numbers for your Twitter followers?
So funny.
It's like follow every day.
There's like a strange obsession.
It's like it's nine,
I think it's nine 60 something,
but I'm getting close.
96 960960900 60,000 holy shit.
But I've,
I've been working,
you're,
you can also hire a million,
you're going to feel different.
You know,
it's,
you know,
I've only over the past month or two started to even have conversations on
there.
Like first of all,
I initially I was like,
I'm not going to have a conversation.
Like there's Twitter things,
we should go over this.
And then I,
but here's the first one.
The first one is,
um,
and some of my friends do this,
so it's like,
it's like to each their own.
It's like when someone says,
uh,
Jim Gaffigan was awesome tonight,
you know,
pardon me.
The desire is to retweet that.
But that's almost bragging.
Yeah.
You get a humble for that.
Right.
And so then there's the,
uh,
um,
there's that.
And then there's even having converse,
like I had always wanted my timeline to just be jokes,
just jokes,
you know,
uh,
like maybe it may be at,
you know,
uh,
an appearance page lists,
you know,
it's like,
I'll be in Tampa,
blah,
blah blah.
By the way,
I will be in five on June 2nd.
No,
and so because Jim gaffigan.com,
Jim gaffigan.com and uh,
so I would do that,
but there's also something insane about that cause it's,
there is something social and there,
you know,
if your friend says something funny,
it would be fun to response.
So I've just been doing that for the past two months.
But how many people do you follow?
I follow a lot.
I follow a lot too.
I follow over a thousand.
It kind of sucks.
I've been thinking about it like cutting my numbers down lately,
but there's so many people are like,
dude,
I told you about the,
I tweeted it like for a week and I've cut,
I've cut a few celebrities.
I was following some celebrities as a goof and it just,
just more onyx shit over and over again and I'd get crazy and I'd have to delete
it.
Well,
if this is a help,
but I also feel like that's,
that's kind of like inviting someone to dinner and then saying,
sorry you can't come,
isn't it?
I don't know.
No,
it's like people unfollow me all the time.
Especially like really douchey people.
I was like,
I'm sure like some woman will will get mad at my not wanting women to be running
things right.
Quote about that early.
You fucking sexist pig by the way.
That all came from watching a woman yell and scream at a guy yesterday.
He's pointing his face and the ridiculous situation where I thought it could
escalate to violence and I might have to step in.
It was like kind of craziness.
Right.
So that's just the origin of that.
So,
you know,
but uh,
well maybe not really.
Maybe I just made that up to you.
Don't know.
We don't know.
I don't know.
But we're going to agree with you because we're sitting in a room with you.
But what was the thing about the Twitter thing?
It,
how about this?
How about like when you have like,
you know,
a comedian,
you know there's friends and then there's peers that you kind of know,
right?
And you'd be like,
Hey,
you know,
I'm going to send them a direct message and then you realize they don't follow
you.
Isn't there a little bit like,
really?
Yeah.
Well you don't follow me.
I've done that accidentally though.
And I apologize.
Like I didn't realize I wasn't following somebody and in this pit people that I
knew I was following there,
for some reason it wasn't.
I've had Twitter.
Twitter's been doing that a lot lately.
And I think it's the iPhone.
I think if you have the iPhone,
you'll have the app open and then you could easily like hit it.
Oh you know,
follow unfollow someone.
Cause it happens to me all the time.
You know what else has happened,
you know,
I used to have a blackberry and I had an iPhone at the same time.
And when I had my blackberry I would go on and check a direct message on Twitter
and then I would go,
I've got to get,
I've got to respond to that eventually,
but I don't have time right now.
And then I would go check it online and there'd be no direct message.
It wouldn't exist anymore.
Well I do,
I didn't know that.
If they a
text message,
it deletes it.
Oh and unethically and everything though.
Somebody could send it to you think that you didn't respond,
just delete it.
Yeah.
And then there's another thing I like go in your book.
If you,
if you go to somebody's page and it says that you're not following them,
if you hit refresh a lot of times and then it will say you're falling.
I'm like,
it just doesn't show up that you're following up.
And so then you might click it thinking like,
ah,
I thought it was [inaudible] and that's unfolding you on.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
So anytime you,
it's like I exist with enough guilt already.
You know?
It's so,
anyway,
I got it.
I eventually sent to go.
You gotta get Outta here right now?
Yeah.
What time is it?
Eight eight 17 or listen to you sexy bitch.
This was fun though.
Thank you.
Anytime.
Please come by.
You're awesome man.
Anytime you want to do it please.
Or how often are you out here in la?
Not that often.
You live in,
in New York City kids.
Four kids.
You live in Manhattan.
Wow.
What does that like with four kids living in my head it's like really hard.
Yeah.
I would say.
How do you,
where do you do with them?
How do you take them?
And we live in a two bedroom.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
So,
wow.
And that's probably $100,000 a month,
right?
It's
fucking ridiculous.
It's insane.
It's just the craziest way to live.
I'm sure my apartment is like half the size of your garage.
Wow.
That's ridiculous.
And you must pay a shit load for it to,
right?
Well,
yeah.
Yeah.
But if a friend has got a $4 million apartment and I was like,
this is $4 million,
this is $4 million.
This is like 1600 bucks a month in Burbank is $4 million in New York.
Cause this fucking craziness.
It's craziness.
It moved to the west coast.
Want to start a podcast?
Yeah,
dude,
if you ever want to come out here,
man,
he was too pale.
Ranier Shit,
I don't,
I'm not a drunk.
I got a criers.
You couldn't imagine the amount of anxiety when I was like,
oh the five's the one 34 to,
I don't drive marijuana in and navigation system and you'll be fine.
Don't worry about it.
It's all figured out.
He'll never have to worry about how to drive.
So with your family.
Okay.
You can't say that you would never,
you could never live here because of the sun,
because you wouldn't be outdoors.
So I did a ginger.
She,
it's fine.
She's wears big hats.
Yeah,
you'd be fine,
dude.
You can do it.
Well,
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of the sun for real.
No.
You know what I,
some of it is,
I think the entertainment business.
I don't know if I want to be that deep end to it.
Yeah,
you're probably right.
I know that mean.
We mean you can live in a completely different world.
In New York,
people are for sure.
The cat's formed the caste system that exists and it would,
oh,
he's on a network show,
so he gets to go here and then here's an indie actor.
So he jumps over you.
Oh,
you're a comedian.
You can go back there with the mines.
Is that how you feel when you're out here?
I think that there is a hierarchy here.
Well,
I think that if you came out here,
just vow.
Mostly I say Jim Gaffigan,
this is what you could do if you came out here and started a fucking podcast and
you devolve
the comics that around here where you could actually even do this in New York if
you want to do,
but your,
you would have a huge podcast.
I think it would be enormous and it would,
I think would change everything.
Change how you promote your club dates,
your,
your theater gigs,
anything you're doing.
It'd be amazing for sure.
Easily people would right away you would,
you'd be in the top.
You'd be in the top five squad.
You'd be in the top five in iTunes right away.
I'm 100% you'd be and I would think that you'd be one of the few people that
would say,
subscribe how you perfect for this man.
I could do it with my wife that she's,
yeah,
that's not a bad idea.
Tom Sigora does it with his wife.
That only works out 50% of the time.
It only works about 50% of the time.
Well,
you mean with fit with couples,
you don't mean like Tom Segura this shit.
Nine bucks.
Half the time.
I'm just saying with couples.
So let's just be clear.
Yeah.
Most of the time they,
it crosses breakup.
So either way it's a win.
It's a win.
Win.
All right,
Jim Gaffigan,
ladies and gentlemen,
and you can get his special when and how?
April 11th April 11th $5.
Five bucks at Jim Gaffigan.
Jim gaffigan.com Ga,
F F I g a n.com.
Dude,
you're the fucking man.
It wasn't,
will it be available on iTunes or Amazon or any of those choices?
Gap.
Just him.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Awesome.
Thank you very much for coming,
sir.
It's a fun,
yeah,
it's always fun to have a comedy,
especially the comment that I don't really get a chance to talk to you,
so it was fun.
Really cool.
Yeah.
Um,
thanks to the fleshlight for sponsoring our lovely podcast.
Please go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link and during the code name Rogan Shaving,
Xavier's show 15% off.
You've heard this before.
What's behind them?
The fleshlight is that girls.
That's a little Esther.
That's a kid.
Now.
She's a grown woman.
Actually.
She's just very,
she calls herself a little tattled on me for parking at the Oh,
a little lesser.
Why don't you go negative on me?
Come and give me a hug and apologize to Brian.
Um,
thank you.
On at.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain.
Go get yourself some always 100% money back guarantee for the first order of 30
30 pills.
You know why it's not more?
Because there's some people out there that are assholes and you used to be,
you can have it all money back 100% all whatever.
You bought a hundred percent money back guarantee,
but then people are selling that shit.
So we had to stop doing that.
It's dirty,
dirty people out there breaking the law,
breaking the law,
cutting through the rule systems,
hacking the system.
They hacked the system.
Jim Gaffigan,
goddammit.
Anyway,
on a.com,
Alpha brain,
shroom tech sport,
shroom tech,
immune and new mood.
Be Five HTP enhancement supplement.
As always,
please Google nootropics.
Get yourself into that shit first.
Check it out.
Find out what the pros and cons,
and uh,
if you're interested in Alpha brain,
go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link and in the Code Day Rogan,
he's saying he'll Rogan dot.
Yeah,
not.com who's a very nice guy by the way.
Don't hurt and said,
what does he go?
It's a real salesman in Idaho.
And he just sent me some email that was accidentally supposed to go to,
maybe it went to him.
And what the fuck is this podcast still going on for good night,
everybody.
We got a packed week.
Tomorrow we have Jason Silva on Tuesday,
Aubrey Marcus.
And then on Wednesday we got Matt from hoarders,
the guy who cleans up after those fucking crazy people.
So we've got a busy week,
right?
You [inaudible] freaks was he sowed by love you olive garden.
Oh,
you did it.
You pitch.